Nico has competed at eight caravizas
he's lost three finals two of which were
consecutive and now finally
he's a champion but that's not all
Hunter was the MVP jks the two team
two-time Money the youngest trophy
hoister ever and hooksy well let's just
say that the G and G2 now officially
stands for Giga chat
all right first things first IHC despite
failing to make it out of groups this
Mongolian Dark Horse was the Cinderella
story of the tournament these guys went
nuclear against a sea of tier one talent
and their Opera Annihilation homie is
cracked and it's assuming too much to
watch from Annihilation half health of
the deagle but it's only two lefts
surely not the bombers facing him this
time swinging now looking for Yuri who's
alone he's isolated it can't be like
this it can't be and then she's got one
more to find this drop these rounds are
so dangerous for Furia next up
complexity was this Hall zurich's skit
the best thing to come out of Cole's
cattle stint yes but the absolute barn
burner they played against Outsiders was
a close second has he given them a
chance they're gonna go grab it they
flushed him out of the pit right away
but what the bombs ended up on the roof
no oh it finally kicker was a little
taller the Norwegians just stole it away
around hats off to the boys and blue man
spending major Champions to the brink
and came excruciatingly close to beating
them I legitimately think that if this
coffin smoke gets thrown a few seconds
earlier and Cole don't swing it before
it blooms they get 14 and maybe maybe
force overtime as for the other boys in
blue
let's start with the positives the win
against FaZe Clan was wild they
exercised some real demons with that one
in fact I think it's safe to say that
we all did
and they see us back on top Grand Slam
here we come suffice it to say their
quarter-final comeback against Vitality
was in no uncertain terms the craziest
[__] I have ever seen 13-2 that was the
deficit not only did liquid bring it
back they took a beating on map 2 only
to eke out map 3 and send the Frenchies
flying Apex that was a must-win fight
it's giving them a chance to root back
in but this one's coming down to the
wire and out with that swing
OC seals the deal all in all a
formidable performance it is sort of
disappointing that they put up such a
lackluster showing against G2 but I do
think they can take some solace in the
fact that G2 are just on one right now
speaking of the aforementioned Gamers 2
bruvs are Untouchable as most of you are
probably aware G2 went into Caddo
boasting one of the longest map streaks
in CS go history and there is a reason
for that that's G2
look to make their dreams a reality
reality
they've done it they did it they clicked
this is the G2 that we've been waiting
for it really feels as if after their
blast went in December everything just
fell into place jks is back in Peak
pre-pandemic shape Hunter is really
really coming into his own modesty's
insane opting has made it so that Nico
can be the star rifler without having to
be a Solo Carry and hooxy being the
solution to g2's problems went from a
meme to a reality but for Nico in
particular this win was Monumental four
cattle finals he's played three of which
he'd lost prior to this one add two
major finals onto that and you've got a
guy who despite being one of the most
statistically impressive riflers ever to
touch the game had never really racked
up a big trophy to his name homie was
desperately deserving of this dub and it
was lovely to watch him get it yeah like
the whole ancient I was not thinking
about the trophy at all I just wanted to
play like it was like a face again
basically and after the last flag
I don't know something just I cannot
describe the feeling but I swear to God
so as I said it's the first time I cry
it means the world to me as for Heroic
it's genuinely hard to know whether
they're suffering from a little bit of a
finals phobia right now like G2 did for
so long or if their opponents are
honestly just that good Outsiders in Rio
were on another level in my opinion and
G2 are on a historic run right now
whatever the case may be I do think
heroic's time will come jabby is insane
Stan is quickly cementing himself as a
world-class rifler and kadian continues
to be a supremely sick entertaining
caller it just feels
big finals that they still need to iron
out once they do that they'll truly be a
first-rate Powerhouse quick to the punch
though Hunter awaits lies and wait the
barrel there the quick switch to The Dig
modesty spotted oh no
that's pretty much it there's a ton more
I could have talked about but I really
sort of wanted to stick to the pressing
stuff incredible event that looks to
Harold a standout year for CS go
can't wait to see what comes next
the guy looks like he just stepped off a
NASCAR track in [__] South Dakota and
he is Norwegian like through and through
like the thickest accent you've ever
heard it was great yeah it's really
funny Halls work is a beauty man I
[__] love Halter I'm gonna need me
everything round